[Musique]
habituellement c'est qu'il arrive et
vous l'avez bien comment at il atterri 6
les mets tout seul dans les bois
je ne pouvais pas le laisser mourir
madame vous savez que vous n'avez pas le
droit d'aller aussi loin et il meurt non
la zone rares 8% le sous la véranda
tous mes voyages je n'ai jamais croisé
beauté plus délicate et puis ce genre
dites moi donc j'ai pas peur si tout
était permis
si vous pouviez obtenir tout ce que vous
vouliez que désire y en ait au moment
même où avis cette toilette ou va ravir
nice edwin art
merci il aurait d'autres d'alizée paul
s'il ne s'était permis d'arborer en tête
des cotes et je reconnais que dans une
école de jeunes filles
ce n'est pas une tenue tout à fait
convenable mais me séverine indien de la
ville les usages sont différents je
suggère que nous parlons d'autre chose
si vous voulez bien et que miss edwina
relève son école merci
cela évitera toute autre réflexion sur
le sujet c'est le meilleur repas que
j'ai mangé depuis des vivres merci
madame merci beaucoup